et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
jean louis debré bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ancien ministre ancien
président du conseil constitutionnel on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
fabrice veysseyre au nom du groupe ebra
les journaux régionaux de l'est de la
france bonjour fabrice aurieng bonjour
jean louis debré bonjour les gens lui
devrait je vous ai présenté comme ancien
ministre et ancien président du conseil
constitutionnel on connaît bien sûr
l'homme politique que vous êtes mais
aujourd'hui nous recevons aussi sur ce
plateau le comédien jean louis debré
vous êtes sur les planches avec une
pièce ces femmes qui ont réveillé la
france avant de parler de la pièce
pourquoi ce choix d'être sur les
planches
parce que
j'ai envie de le faire partager de
transmettre de manière parfois
humoristique notre histoire l'histoire
de la république et que dans cette pièce
le jouer avec valérie bochenek et avec
une pianiste
amiens on parle de qui on parle de ce
combat de ces femmes qui avaient compris
la république et la république s'est
naturellement marianne mais c'est
liberté égalité fraternité
il n'y a pas de liberté sans égalité et
il n'y a pas de fraternité sans égalité
que ça soit la première bachelière la
première médecin la première avocate
tout avait ce combat en tête et
ça me plaît de communiqué hier soir il y
avait une classe entière qui est venu et
après quoi je parlais avec les jeunes
apprenons notre histoire de la
république c'est une autre façon de
faire de la politique jean louis debré
pardon c'est une autre façon de faire de
la politique pour vous pour moi c'est la
politique je la regarde avec 10 ans et
avec détachement je m'y intéresse mais
parfois je ne comprends plus totalement
les équations de la politique mais vous
avez choisi
deux façons d'avoir des grandes voix
comme jean je sens comme colette
[Musique]
comme simone veil les bois qui ont donné
des directions et puis des pionnières
l'histoire est écrite par des hommes qui
connaît la première bachelière qui s'est
battu battu pour avoir le droit de
passer le baccalauréat première médecin
première mais ça
quand
on regarde pas ce que tu ça c'est un
rallye que j'avais écrit avec valérie
welsh nec et on les allées aux archives
quand vous avez
le journal les messins qui dit beaupré
pour faire une carrière médicale pour
qu'une femme facile car et médicales il
faut qu'elle perde sa qualité de femme
parce que de par l'aspect psychologique
la femme médecin est un être
un monstre mais ça veut dire que ces
femmes elles n'ont pas la place qu'elle
mérite dans l'histoire aujourd'hui je
pense que trop souvent
on ne raconte que l'histoire des hommes
la république elle que nous partageons
que nous aimons que j'aime elle a été le
fruit d'hommes et de femmes
qui ont encore une fois ont voulu que
les règles de l'égalité s'applique quand
je parle
de la première femme musulmans et
musulmanes membre d'un gouvernement de
la république qui se souvient et qui se
souvient de ce que alors elle a dit
c'était en 1959 sa pleine la fils ainsi
de kara et elle a été élevée par les
instituteurs de la république et elle
dit à quoi à ses frères et soeurs
algérienne à l'époque et bien
enlever le voile c'est le signe de la
liberté
ça ne veut pas dire que vous renoncez à
votre religion mais soyez égales aux
hommes alors il ya une femme qui
aimerait bien rentrer dans l'histoire
comme première présidente de la
république c'est valérie pécresse vous
connaissez bien est-ce que d'abord elle
a eu raison de commencer son premier
discours à peine son élection annoncée
par le fait qu'elle était une femme et
que sa famille politique avait choisi
une femme pour la première fois ça vous
est absolument me faire revenir et
thierry vous savez
moi qui essayent de m'échapper de la
politique
rien
d'abord un je me garderai bien de faire
le moindre pronostic pour l'instant j'ai
vous avez rappelé que j'ai fait la
politique je me souviens que en février
personne n'aurait parié sur la victoire
de jacques chirac je me souviens que
giscard d'estaing quatre mois avant le
renouvellement de son mandat personne
n'imaginait qu'il pourrait être battu
par françois mitterrand nicolas sarkozy
samoa avant la fin son mandat personne
imaginez qu'ils ne puissent pas faire un
deuxième mandat pour vous tout est
possible dans cette élection je pense
que tout est possible et le fait que ce
soit une femme qui
je connais les journalistes politiques
très bien et si je viens pas la question
que pose la question
moi qui voulais parler du théâtre et de
ces femmes qui rit à france mais vous
voulez dire que pécresse va réveiller la
france c'est ça
je pense que
il ya quelque chose ces appareils est
très intéressant aujourd'hui c'est il ya
très peu de périodes dans notre histoire
politique ou la société politique n'a
pas construit de personnages évident on
ne pouvait compter c'est mitterrand mais
il a dominé la gauche on pouvait compter
c'est giscard mais là dominé à droite on
pouvait compter c'est chirac mais la
dominer n'avait pas besoin de faire de
primaire il s'imposait
aujourd'hui plus personne ne s'impose et
c'est révélateur de quoi pour vous
c'est flatteur
beaucoup je l'expliqué dans dans ce
livre sur l'humour
aujourd'hui le le si cela la politique
est devenue un véritable métier du
spectacle dire que on ne cherche pas à
créer une espérance a créé avoir un
discours sur des petites phrases pour
être dues pour que vous repreniez c'est
israël et donc on a asséché le discours
politique et
deuxièmement ce trou pardon parce que
j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur pour ce
livre quand il prédit faisait rire sur
les archives le niveau de culture d un
politique quand vous aviez un débat
entre jaurès et clemenceau kelly culture
quand vous aviez des discours de jaurès
mais disco de clemenceau d'arrêt si
brillant vous êtes impressionné quand
vous regardez et bullies est aujourd'hui
lé discours
c 'est technocratique c'est à dire que
jadis
le parlementaire n'était pas entourée de
collaborateurs il improvisait il avait
des convictions il avait une volonté
or aujourd'hui on ne trouve plus cela
mais c'est spécifique aux politiques
mais c'est le syndrome d'un
affaiblissement de l'école aujourd'hui
en france ne mangeait pas compétent je
constate simplement qu'il y à une
uniformisation dix courses je prends
j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur les
professions de foi il y a trente ans la
profession de foi du députés et les
sénateurs étaient très intéressants
parce que c'était lui qui l'a rédigé et
donc on voyait la personnalité de du
candidat aujourd'hui c'est le parti qui
envoie les professions de foi toutes
faites et vous prenez du lot-et-garonne
à l'heure en passant par l'allié et la
somme s'ils sont les mêmes il rajoute
leur nom en bas
s'il n'y a plus cet enrichissement de la
diversité et donc
je regarde ça avec intérêt ce que je
constate c'est que
le chemin parcouru par valérie pécresse
a été un chemin qui a donné de l'espoir
à la droite après je critique pas le
résultat est là pour une fois est arrivé
alors que à gauche et à droite tu ça
c'était l'ennemi et non à rassembler et
à redonner l'espoir est ce qu'elle peut
compter sur vous pas quoi est ce qu'elle
peut compter sur vous mais moi je ne
suis qu'un citoyen de loi non je ne suis
qu'un citoyen je voterai
mais je connais bien aux questions
je pense que les sons et nos citoyens
nos concitoyens libre pas besoin de deux
je ne suis plus rien je ne représente
rien je joue au théâtre j'ai une autre
carrière ferez peut-être du cinéma dans
lequel causes telles que j'écris j'écris
des des livres
je vois là je veux sortir j'ai toute ma
vie j'avais qu'une angoisse
être un ancien être un ancien magistrat
alors j'ai quitté la magistrature être
un ancien parlementaire à l'ancien
parlementaire qui est toujours au
parlement j'avais écrit obsession c'est
le qui sied la politique avant qu'elle
ne me quitte
je me suis mis à écrire des livres quel
bonheur d'avoir un autre contact tous
les soirs au théâtre
après la pièce eh bien je suis à la
sortie et je parle avec les gens pressés
vous disent les gens il me parle alors
il parle de la pièce il dirige et drôle
en scène on a beaucoup ri mais très
rapidement
comme vous parce que l'on peut pas me
regarder mais sans penser immédiatement
à la politique c'est sur des réflexes
conditionnés sous les j'arrive je vous
croise pas une politique je préférais
coup parler de bicyclettes de marche à
pied 2 4 mais peu importe est donc très
rapidement pour et il me parle alors ce
qui est ce qui m'intéresse c'est pas de
leur donner mon avis parce que je n'ai
aucun c'est de recueillir leurs
sentiments et
aujourd'hui il ya plusieurs phénomènes
que je ressens une sur nostalgie du
passé
à du temps de c'était sur la sagi
aucune identification
d'affections comme on pouvait le marquer
à l'égard du général de gaulle de
mitterrand de chirac non une résignation
et cette nostalgie vous la partagez avec
vos spectateurs
nostalgie on l'a sur la cible je pense
que
qu'est-ce qui me disent même les gens
qui sont pas
favorables
avec chirac au moins il nous est mais au
moins il nous aimait il était de chez
nous
jaurès à ce que je viens de dire que
peintre aux journalistes
simplement il ya ce sentiment
d'ailleurs si liés au développement de
l'antiparlementarisme et de l'abstention
et la classe politique
et ils ont un peu de distance jeu sur 7
sur nostalgie parce que c'est
intéressant de 7 sur 7 g dont vous nous
parlez est ce que pour vous ça peut
expliquer la montée d'eric zemmour qui
fait lui campagne sur la france d'avant
et sur cette nostalgie du passé il veut
je sais pas pour quelle campagne ip mais
moi j'ai un sentiment
moi je parlerais de lui mieux je me
porterai
il faut pas en parler pour vous je ne
représente pas tous ici mais
vous savez
la démocratie à la république elle a
besoin de fonctionner avec des partis
républicains une gauche républicaine on
n'est pas content de la gauche le
week-end on va alors un très bon
week-end et donc la responsabilité c'est
que à gauche et à droite républicaine on
est des hommes ou des femmes qui portent
l'étendard on les a aujourd'hui
notamment
à droite non
c'est à fait vous savez un mot parce
qu'on pourparlers internes ont été lus
en créant une espérance mitterrand a été
élu sur les 110 propositions
parce que elle était lisible peu importe
savoir si les appliquer ou pas
appliquées après mais l'élection
une porte et une espérance chirac c'est
l'ascenseur social or on a le sentiment
aujourd'hui que pour les politiques la
politique ce n'est pas de régler les
problèmes c'est de faire taire ceux qui
les posent
vous restez quand même quand on vous
écoute bien vous restez partisans du
bipartisme une droite une gauche et
pourtant quand on revient cinq ans en
arrière il me semble que jean louis
debré avait dit qu'il voterait emmanuel
macron partisans du en même temps oui
mais je vous avais très bonne mémoire
mais j'ai
une très grande déception et c'est pour
ça que je suis très sceptique
aujourd'hui
même si je dis je suis très sceptique
mais nous avons encore quatre mois
interrogé mois dans quatre mois je
dirais mais pour l'instant si je me
concentre sur le théâtre sur ces femmes
qu'on verrait la france jette quand même
sur sur la politique alors le terrain
compris que je ne veux pas parler des
examens mais vous nous parler de jacques
chirac on voudrait juste vous faire
réagir à ce qu'a dit eric zemmour je
suis très haut sur jacques chirac juste
on va lutter oui je sais je un tony dix
fois on a juste à écouter jean louis
debré zone et
il réussit ce qu'ils cherchent c'est que
depuis quelques jours on balance toutes
ces petites phrases mois
m'engager dans une campagne électorale
je m'engage sur une espérance sur
quelqu'un tu as apporté non pas sur des
petites phrases absolument assassine
méchante qui n'ont aucun sens et qui
sont pour moi inutile et on rabaisse sa
politique moi je souhaite que les gens
me donnent de l'espérance et je suis
prêt à suivre à écouter à comprendre des
gens qui disent voilà la france que l'on
veut construire voilà le contrat social
qui qui doit être le nôtre ces petites
phrases vous réduisez la politique à
un ping pong de petites phrases
pas que mais juste un mot sur ce qu'il a
dit
en 1995
jacques chirac entrait à l'elysée et
pourtant et pourtant toutes ces belles
proclamations de villepin qui restèrent
lettre morte toutes ces belles promesses
furent oubliés
la droite
la droite comme d'habitude se soumettait
aux injonctions de la gauche et médias
des juges la droite comme d'habitude
trahissait ses électeurs aussitôt qu'il
avait misé sur le pavois valérie
pécresse rappelle sans cesse
rappelle sans cesse
que son entrée en politique est
intimement lié à la personne de jacques
chirac elle serait faire sans cesse à
lui croyons là sur parole elle agira
comme son mentor elle promettra tout et
ne retiendra rien
c'est pas trop ça n'est pas vrai ce
n'est pas votre droite et moi je ne suis
pas à droite je suis gaulliste est votre
réaction à ce que je trouve que c'est
faux
dangereux et en plus pour lui absurde
parce que si il se met à dos tous les
électorats il va finir en dessous de
zéro
jean lui devrait eric zemmour qui
attaquent le conseil constitutionnel a
évidemment on voudrait votre réaction en
tant qu'ancien président du conseil
constitutionnel à propos de son plan
pour lutter contre l'immigration il me
dit on ne peut l'appliquer ctions se
débarrasse des contraintes juridiques de
la cndh et du conseil constitutionnel en
2016 il disait déjà eric zemmour comme
michel debré avait conçu le conseil
constitutionnel juste pour surveiller le
parlement et non pour se transformer en
cour suprême puisse arriver là il m'a
attaqué et matraqué parce que j'avais
fait la qpc mais bon
je la corde à ce qu'il dit aujourd'hui
aucun intérêt car il veut et il arrive
il veut qu'on reprenne ses propos comme
ils nous proposent rien on aurait été de
près si aucune espérance et qui l'aidant
dans la haine dans l'excessif sert à ça
ne veut pas dire qu'ils ne posent pas
aussi de vraies questions notamment sur
la lutte contre l'immigration illégale
mais c'est pas en bon on ne sera pas
contre l'immigration illégale en
supprimant tout et revenant de quoi en
revenant qu'à période de la révolution
où on la laisse tribunaux populaires on
a
un sérieux
renom théâtre salerno alors sur le tête
même si on en a beaucoup parlé mais
juste sur le tête parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de jeunes qui gène cretz voir
cette pièce qui viennent vous voir
beaucoup d'écoliers beaucoup de les gens
qu'est ce qu'ils ont vu mais pourquoi
parce que à nos jeunes on leur apprend
lui 16 14 on ne leur apprend pas
l'histoire de la république et
l'histoire des idées de la république et
cette pièce que je veux drôle et on a un
jeu de ping-pong avec valérie bochenek
c'est pour dire assez assez jeune il n'y
a pas que l'histoire de la monarchie de
l' empire il ya l'histoire des idées
comment aujourd'hui des hommes et des
femmes qui sont pas des extrémistes
ont pu faire progresser dans notre pays
le sentiment d'égalité mais du coup
pardon je reviens à ma question tout à
la messe qui a pas une feuille de
l'école relations si oui
je pense qu'on devrait
enseigner
plus d'histoire des idées de la
république de la république pour faire
naître chez nos jeunes le sentiment que
la république leur appartient là bas la
république c'est pas la chose de
quelques hommes politiques c'est la
chose du peuple il faut faire vivre la
république vous avez à titre personnel à
titre politique a company is toute cette
vème république au et connaissait sur le
bout des doigts
vous évoquiez l'abstention tout à
l'heure vous évoquez l'espérance est ce
que cette république n'a pas besoin
d'être relancé le débat de la sixième
république n'est pas revenu dans le nom
de sujets politiques du moment est ce
que cette république n'est pas en panne
je pense que
il faudrait commencer par revenir sur un
certain nombre de réformes qui ont abîmé
la république thème république comme
lesquels lesquels je pense que le
quinquennat est une absurdité tout le
monde y a voulu utiliser la mode voulue
par pompidou repris par me serrant dans
ses 110 propositions
soutenues par giscard une fois qu'ils
avaient fini sept ans après repris par
jose pas adoptée par chirac tout le
monde au nom de l'idée à la mode on se
rend compte que pour réformer pour
modifier pour conduire un pays il faut
de la durée deuxièmement revenons sur la
concomitance entre l'élection
présidentielle élection des députés
la régime de la vème république est un
régime qui pouvait être si avait
concordance ans et majorité
présidentielle s'ils n'y avaient pas
concordance d'alternance parlementaire
revenons aussi ça je le dis parce que
j'ai vécu ça sur la possibilité pour un
député ou pour un sénateur d'être maire
d'une ville peut-être accumulé trop de
fonctions comme président de commune
mais vous présente comme une
départementale connexion entre le
national et local une fonction
d'exécutif local vous permet d'avoir
d'être enracinés d'être à l'écouté quand
j'étais député et maire des heureux tous
les tous les samedis ou dimanches
j'étais sur les marchés à evreux je vais
le tour des commerçants j'écoutais
troisièmement revenons à la session
unique
aujourd'hui on s'y laisse tout le temps
c'est absurde ça pourrait peut-être
faire des lois moins longue
car une des caractéristiques c'est pas
beaucoup plus de lois mais c'est des
lois de plus en plus longues et dans la
fabrication des lois revenons à ce qui
était un principe essentiel de la
république c'est que les affirmations
politiques vont dans l'exposé des motifs
et qu'on fait des lois avec peu de
dispositions mais des dispositions
précises donc revenons un certain nombre
de réformes qui ont dit nature et la
vème république
après je pense que on pourrait revoir un
peu le fonctionnement du parlement
notamment dans l'intercession où on peut
imaginer dans l'intercession juste une
séance des questions d'actualité en plus
je pense que un rôle du parlement et de
plus en plus d'être un contrôle
permanent de l'administration or on les
commissions exerce ce contrôle
d'ailleurs quand j'étais présent à
l'assemblée j'ai fait que le président
de la commission ne soit pas la
coloration politique du rapporteur mais
le rendu le rendu de ces commission
denquête elle n'est pas clair de même
lorsqu'on commence le budget il devrait
y avoir un débat officiel bien précis
sur l'exécution du budget précédent pour
compte bien mis on ferait passer à
tribune ministre par ministre on vous a
voté ce crédit est ce qu'il a été
exécuté vous avez voté cette loi est ce
que les décrets d'application de cet
article cost donc il devrait y avoir
pendant un mois ou qu'un jour avant la
discussion budgétaire une vraie
confrontation entre les députés les
sénateurs et l'exécution du budget
précédent vous voyez vous avez encore
beaucoup d'idées pour la france jean
louis debré on était ravi de les
entendre ce matin merci beaucoup et même
période et justement j'invite nos
téléspectateurs à aller au théâtre de la
gaîté montparnasse et jusqu'à fin mars
prolonger jusqu'à fin mars et après mois
de mars nous faisons une tournée en
province où vous voyez ça nouveau métier
ces femmes qui ont réveillé la france et
votre pièce de théâtre et puis votre
livre également quand les politiques
nous faisait rire c'est à lire et
j'invite également nos téléspectateurs à
le dire merci jean louis debré merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin
[Musique]